du bist nicht Gronkh was hast du mit ihm
gemacht hast du ihn entführt Andreas
ja also mit Kong ist es so
sehr gut dass ich jetzt hier bin ich
kann es jetzt auch sagen
es ist tatsächlich so ich bin nicht
krank aber ich habe Gronkh entführt und
ich hätte gerne
also jeder der Gronk sehen möchte also
er ist in meiner Gewalt ich habe den an
einem sicheren Ort verwahrt und jeder
der kommt sehen möchte muss mir ich
werde hier nachher dann auch
noch bekannt geben wo äh das Geld
hinüberwiesen werden soll ich möchte
also eine Menge Kohle dafür haben und
jeder User muss mir mindestens 1 €
überweisen
also jeder der kommt sehen möchte ihr
wisst bescheid und vorher lasse ich ihn
auch nicht frei